hi everyone I'm Milano Oh char Lanza and
today you are watching a video of my
lightning cosplay which we are getting
lots of photos of yeah more than
anything I chose lightning because a lot
of people always comment on my photos
like it's true whatever and say that my
pan looks a lot I could so I was like I
can totally do that but the hottest play
about the shoot was actually that the
way that's kept swallowing my hair wet
and lightnings hey is so perfect all the
time and cutting these bullets then you
just got really frustrating
but it was also really hard to kind of
get everything together I put hours and
hours into this especially it's not
enough has actually chicken wire I
shaped the chicken wire around my arm so
that I do fit perfectly then we use
paper over the tongue and then a tough
depth which is paper and then and I
thought think of bits of paper for the
bits that are raised and just sort of
shaped through the way that I need and
then a heel of a lot of paint to smooth
that out it's still very obviously looks
like paper mache but for something that
took me such a long amount of time that
I immediately thought would fail because
it's not a conventional way to make mama
I'm actually surprised that it worked
out he's super glue no to these bits
which I don't see the question
[Music]
I think it probably took me about 25
hours to make the mama as well as the
shoes which had to cut up my fabric
store and then get buckles bar and it's
so stuff will generally don't go that
hopefully next time can I try and
cosplay something requires sewing and
crafting it'll take me a lot less time
but I think 2530 out
[Music]
[Music]
this is my second Emma cosplay my bust
was Riddler but really when I started
going to conventions and see if you
pressed up for the same characters that
I really like and the way people acted
it out it's just a really really
exciting environment and I know that I
don't even look like lightning I
definitely didn't look like the middle
of me but that's a male character it
doesn't really matter you know when
you're in characters just a lot of fun
sorry it was something I just sort of
jumped it
what thank you guys for watching that is
it for me today I wish you guys next
time if you want to see a link to my
facebook is Momo weathers in Thai all
thank you guys watching
[Music]